[Music]
two one hello everyone welcome to
simulation we have a very awesome
episode coming at you we're gonna be
talking about transformative technology
emotional well-being health joy we have
Nicole Bradford joining us today thank
you thank you really appreciate it
thanks for having me and this has been a
long time of pursuing transformative
technology now for you it's been four
years yeah this is our fourth year for
the lab and you know this is it's
exciting now because it's like the world
is catching up to what we've been
pointing out and that's really exciting
to see the level of interest globally
from people in technology for mental
health well-being enjoy yes and what a
tree out there mental health well-being
enjoy because the world we really got to
figure out how to maximize our own
potential and the collective potential
and those three are right there at the
center of of thy self understanding
thyself yeah yeah we sort of think about
the way to think about it is human
psychology is the spectrum and so on one
hand side the way we think about mental
health that includes things like stress
anxiety depression and in the middle is
the human condition it's also where
social-emotional skills really come into
play so that's happiness loneliness
connection meaning making is one of the
most important skills that you can have
for success in life and also the ability
to establish you know connection which
has a great deal to do with trust self
Trust trust of others these are actually
all skills including like compassion
compassion is also a skill the entire
you know there's the entire Buddhist
literature is about the Train ability of
compassion so there's all these things
that are teachable trainable skills that
support social emotional well-being and
then the far side is you know where it
gets really interesting - which is on
the expansion of the mental and
emotional capacity of humans and that's
where you know it's really about like
what more could we do what how much more
can we feel how much more can we
understand about ourselves and one
another and what happens when more of us
are wired that way and you know and able
to connect on that level how much you
know all of this you know how much
creativity would we have how much more
innovation and ingenuity
how many more problems that humanity is
facing could we solve and so you know
within that psychological framework
there are technologies for every piece
and products for every piece that people
have made or are in the process of
making you know leaning towards
understanding and so it's quite exciting
this idea that you can and kind of
radical for many this idea that you can
you know that we can use technology not
just to make things go faster or to you
don't have someone come pick us up in a
car that we don't know but then we could
actually use technology to understand
ourselves better to connect more deeply
and actually to amplify our humanity and
so that's a big that's a big premise of
transformative tech yes I love the way
that you describe that and I don't think
I've actually heard psychology kind of
put on that sort of a spectrum before so
you have on one side the really bad
anxiety or depression it's kind of like
the one of the worst sort of states that
someone could be in and then in the
middle is kind of this like happiness
sadness etc kind of different emotional
states and then as well and then the far
side is just this like explosion of
understanding yourself and how
other people understand themselves and
figuring out how to just synergize
humanity together so I love that sort of
a spectrum and I think you you you know
we have some really good slides in here
to to kind of show this as well but you
also kind of taught me about on Maslow's
hierarchy of needs you show that a lot
of what the work of transformative
technology is is how do you you know
these basic physiological needs are met
and then what happens above that yeah
yeah and that's that's really important
too because you know if you think about
everything that you've heard about
what's going to happen with the future
of work and what tasks within jobs are
going to be gone so you know it's clear
from all the statistics that are all the
forecasts that nobody has any idea you
know it's like that in terms of the
future of work or the rise of automation
the difference between an optimist and
the pessimist is how long it's going to
take not if it's going to happen yes and
how prepared we are and how prepared we
are and so you know one of the biggest
forecasts that I've seen is that 47
percent of all tasks within current jobs
will be automated by 2050 right yeah and
so what that means is that you know
where we used to a lot of work is very
rote where we used to spend a lot of
time doing we're actually going to have
to spend a lot of time being and so
that's being creative being
collaborative being communicative you
know and we're not good at that and we
don't teach that in our society formally
yeah it is you're expected to pick it up
from your culture
you're expect or the culture maybe you
pick it up from your family maybe you
pick it up from a mentor so it's like we
kind of have this crazy situation where
the future requires people who are good
at being not just so that they're
employable but also so that they can
handle change because you know I what
was that one quote that change is faster
than it's ever been that slow as it's
ever going to be ever again so once you
can work and to
you can handle the change the skills
that come you know that it required for
that as a society globally we don't
teach yep yeah it's just yesterday
observing just human watching watching
and I was just seeing people in
cognitively repetitive tasks that were
just they were they looked like they
wanted to creatively explode and explore
and that they were unable to and that
restriction and limitation on the human
spirit due to the pressures of the
economic system drive me nuts too yeah
and that that's our future is figuring
out how to unleash that creativity out
of people but like you said we're not
teaching it how do we teach it across
the world in the age of automation how
do we get ready for that I'm really
happy that we have you and you're you're
making a big push in this direction
through a couple different things you
know we have the the conference the
Academy the lab these three sort of
pillars of transform of technology this
is kind of like this is the hierarchy
that we were talking about earlier
and you know here love and belonging
self esteem self actualization self
transcendence and you know this is
something that I want to you know break
down with you more it's closer it's
closer to the end of you know of what
over in the middle issue of what we're
talking about let's see if we can also
I'm just interested if we can even get
through some of like the major ones in
here but does that show up on the web
yeah yeah it does it shows up on both at
the same time yeah and usually we even
have it shown the TV in studio
well we're work we're working on because
we got you know Eddie sub Eddie comes in
as as when when Ron is away as well and
we're still working on making sure that
everything is like you know these is
good in that way and that we got it
shout out to Eddie our producer Andrew
hey Eddie so you listen you know you
listed home of Deus here as you
exactly just like the next part of human
agenda we were talking about this
earlier kind of like the let the left to
right on the on the scale of of
psychology yeah these are all the things
that are going up like these things are
going up all over the world stress
anxiety depression suicide people are
having a really hard time with change
and it's more than you've talked to
people who are sort of you know really
work in that area day to day it's more
than just higher levels of observation
you know there's like there's more than
that now you know that doesn't mean that
like there's probably some you know
there's probably some things around you
know the definite the clinical
definition of depression used to be sort
of like if you have all these stat you
know if all these things are going on
you might be depressed unless you've had
a death in the you know you've had a
death in the family within three months
that's not in there anymore so maybe
there's more people you know that are
getting scooped into these definitions
but then across the board around the
world the overall number of people who
are falling into these buckets is higher
so there is something going on people
are having a hard time with change a lot
of it is compounded also by then the the
social media culture as well yeah we got
a ton of sort of pressure on us about
this is what happiness looks like and
then that is constantly pushing down on
us and our on our psyche as it also is
motivating at times to be like I want to
achieve that goal and then like you can
also strive to achieve that goal yeah
but there's there's a lot that goes into
this including the example we were
talking about earlier just people being
in work that isn't fulfilling to their
potential yeah yeah I love this this is
the this is what we call the well-being
spectrum and that you can see like there
are some very distinct places where
people need support but there's also so
much more about what's possible
and about you know the the ways that we
can enhance people's skill sets in order
to have you know happiness connection
meaning you know there was a I was
really inspired by a study that was
recently completed on meaning-making and
it was an hour and a half intervention
that was done with middle school high
school and college students and it was
just an hour-and-a-half intervention and
it was done live you know human to human
but the teachers of those kids did not
know who got the you know the meaning
making intervention and who didn't and
so it was completely it was done by a
couple of universities and it was set up
you know of course around all of the
scientific rigor and the outcome and
then they they they taught them how to
make empowered meeting making left till
graduation of that stage and the kids
who had learned how to make positive
meaning making substantially higher
graduation rates grades and the
willingness to go on to the next step
and so you know what is when I hear that
I don't necessarily think okay we should
have these workshops everywhere I think
why can't Alexa do that yeah totally you
know why can't why can't you know the
chat bots aren't quite smart enough to
do it yet but why couldn't they you know
at some point we're all going to have a
personalized AI yep you know so it's
like why couldn't the systems around you
challenge your thinking yeah right now
the best well I think another good
example where you just described
meaning-making is future authoring
there's another good one that kind of
pairs the other with that if you just
simply at the beginning of the year
write down the goals that you want to
achieve that year and have some
short-term goals month month and then
have some long term goals and then at
the end of the year just check in with
yourself on how you did on those goals
and just author your future in that
it's write about it and follow through
on those goals be conscientious about it
you have a much more higher likelihood
of achieving all the things that you
listed there and then you gave this
perfect example of chatbots we already
have you probably had a bunch of things
in your calendar today and a lot of
people watching this have these items in
their calendar and if you you know if
you if if maybe in your calendar it said
email Nicole and then you your Gmail
sees that you didn't email Nicole rather
than needing to go and program tons of
notifications into that one calendar
event that would then remind you every
15 minutes to try and email you just you
know just have a check-in via your voice
at home and just be like Alan I've
noticed you haven't emailed Nicole yet
there's so many of these different or
like you know another good example is
that you know it is it just been well
documented that gratitude makes people
happier slow down in meditate for two
minutes right now right well so I'll
give you an example so gratitude makes
people happier now there is a decay
curve on gratitude in the sense that you
have to actually be grateful for
different things so if you're grateful
for days in a row for health on the
fourth day you're you know your before
and afters you're not you didn't get
quite the bump so you just need to
change it every day that kind of thing
so many things your home your food your
water your yeah tricity yeah but for a
transformative technology and tell you a
quick funny story so a little while ago
I was on a date and I and so the person
I was on a date with his phone rang and
he was like oh my god I'm so sorry I
have to you know take this and I was
like I mean I'm I meditated a lot so I
was like sure no problem and and he's
always a conscientious person so I
didn't take it badly and he picks up the
phone and he says the three best things
that happened today are and so he starts
practicing gratitude and I was like
what's that yeah and it's basically a
voice bot that calls him every day at 6
o'clock and has him list and it goes
speech-to-text
and he can then search it and so you
know one of the things about
transformative technology wait what is
this called
it's a beta I don't remember the name I
love that idea yeah but it sank you're
you're on but if you think about you
know there's things that we know that
work and we can use technology to take
the friction out of it because you know
and maybe there's something about you
know a difference between you writing
yourself or something like that but if
it's the difference between you not
doing it at all and you're doing it a
little bit every day I would take a
little bit every day so you know one of
the one of the things behind
transformative technology also is like
how do we take the friction out of
people doing basic things that are
already good for them and that's exactly
right that you find things like the
phone call that comes in and at six
o'clock every day and you say the things
that you're grateful for and then you're
right and then it just takes the voice
of test.txt League and gives you a
searchable database there's millions of
other ideas like that that I want them I
want them all over the world yeah
there's lots of things you support a lot
of them yeah that's that's what we do so
what's the transformative technology
what the transformative technology lab
does we have three things that we do the
first thing is we do basic research so
we have medical grade EEG and my
co-founder supports he's a PhD in
psychology and he supports postdoc
people who are working on research and
we've got like these medical grade EEG
and they can come through and they have
access to it and can do their research
and he helps with a research the second
thing that we do and that research is
all into sort of like well a particular
interest of ours is matching people to
the right intervention and so like our
meditation program our meditation
research is about matching people to the
right meditation technique
and we could kind of come back to that
but you know whether it's meditation or
some of the big researchers and
Happiness people are starting to come to
this thing that seems really obvious but
it's just not been sort of you know
proven in a lot of the different
intervention categories with science
that different things work for different
people makes sense but it's not proven
it's like dogs are empathetic like that
just came out and everyone's like yeah
we knew that but we didn't actually know
it but now we know it right so we do
that then the second thing we do is we
create communities so that's the
transformative technology conference and
this is our fourth year and we've last
year we had over 600 people yes and we
are the biggest conference for people
who want to build these technologies
because the third part of our mission is
to support entrepreneurs and innovators
because like my belief in our belief is
that sustainable change comes from
sustainable businesses yeah and so we're
all about that's what you're creating
businesses or helping people create
businesses and then the other thing is
that you know what startups are is the
fair experiments and you know this
radical idea of using technology for the
you know inner development of humans
it's actually kind of new we've been
thinking about it for a while but you
know out there it's kind of many people
like wow it makes sense but it's new to
them and so there's so many different
types of human beings there's going to
need to be many different types of
interventions and you know we're not
going to be able to think of them all
you know you know at all and so you know
what our efforts around entrepreneurship
is about is really sort of like engaging
with the you know the the mind of the
world the brain of the web all the
brilliant people out there who are in
the interconnected connected to the web
connected to technology who have real
problems in their communities around you
know whether they're dealing with a
human support issue or whether they you
know see young people who don't know
what it is they want and don't know how
navigate through to those decisions so
everything and they say I want to make
something and so this way instead of it
just being myself and you know Mikey
seagull and a few other people there's
you know an army of Jedi's out there you
know working on this so like with our
Academy which is the third part we've
had we're currently accepting
applications for the program oh yeah
this is our whole ecosystem we're
currently accepting applications for the
program and we have had applicants from
over three hundred and fifteen cities 55
countries yes lots of places that you
would not expect and we accept people
with companies and we accept people who
are interested because it's such a new
space I think that you know unlike you
know Enterprise SAS sales software
that's been around for such a long time
I think some of the best entrepreneurs
in the space are currently working for
you know they're working at other
startups they're working at big
companies through you know because they
didn't even know they could do this yes
but this is where the heart is and so
you know so those people are in our
program too are gonna be in our program
too and so it's just like it's all you
know the world is really starting to
focus in on this and there's some other
reasons why I think it's all clicking
but that's that's kind of what we do and
you're really into this stuff which is
one of the reason you were like hey come
over and talk it was a yes yeah because
you're all about you know you're you are
so interested and have been all about
like human possibility human performance
you with potential and you know
curiosity innovation yeah I want to give
so many marbles over to the transfer of
technology side of things and I was just
you know I was running these these
thought experiments in my head while you
were speaking and I thought to myself
well what if humans decided to as they
earned money to funnel the money rather
than
in a second car second house second boat
what if they funneled it into the
entrepreneurs at the transformative
technology lab or at the academy what if
they did that and what would what would
happen to the results of the lab or to
the entrepreneurs at the Academy how
would that maximize the success of all
the flourishing that could happen what
do you really need the second house for
the second car for the second boat for I
was thinking about that and then I was
also thinking about just I like the
structure of your ecosystem itself that
that having to be the way that the mind
is being shaped by the technologies
actually objectively measured through
things like EEG in through just
cutting-edge psychologists
neuroscientists and and data scientists
just really being able to make sure that
that technology's at the cutting edge
and then on this like next pillar of
having a congregation of people of 600
plus people to come out and and
celebrate this and this is happening in
November this year
yeah November 8th and 9th 8th or not in
Palo Alto yep is that a zit at Sofia
University on earth no we're actually
gonna be a conference location a
conference location 8th and 9th yeah
November 8th and 9th be there if you
want to build technology for the human
condition mental and emotional
well-being this is the only place in the
world for you to be hell yeah hell yeah
good plug hundred percent also plug
Lincoln by OTT Kampf dot yeah TT contour
and can bio check that out ok so then
and there's tons of opportunities for
the Academy as well when when does the
application for the Academy close yeah
there's a there's a couple more weeks it
closes at the end of August and then the
program starts September 15th to October
15th and it's completely online it's no
fee no equity funded by donors and the
purpose is to find the entrepreneurs and
innovators around the world
who are working in this space and we are
not going to we're not you know it's not
like a traditional online startup
program there's so much good startup
content out there we're not recreating
any of that we're gonna do things like
office hours with fantastic HRV experts
yeah so like you actually get a chance
of heart rate variability yeah you
actually get a chance to talk to someone
who can help you or people who you know
have a specific thing about
transformative technology so you know an
investor and the way that they look at
these things so as you are you know
learning how to talk to people you know
what specifically in this space or we
have someone who's going to who's done a
you know a big overview of startups and
is going to and has a love for
transformative tech and is basically
going to outline all the places where
companies in this space misstep which is
probably that's probably one of the most
valuable things for the thing you know
is so for people to like understand
where other people have missed made
missteps so they don't have to do it yep
you know and that's that's also one of
the things that we want to do is to
really disseminate the information so
that people understand the landscape and
understand what's been done and what's
happening so that they can go off in a
new direction because an entrepreneur is
the most important resources their time
their lifeblood like these people you
know they give so much you know they
should either sort of knowingly be doing
what's been done before because they
think that they can do it better and
they have a specific thesis why or
charting new territory because there's
so much territory to cover so it's sort
of like you know it's sort of like going
forth
I love how you are not doing the classic
kind of like entrepreneurship
accelerator where you're you know
bringing you're bringing everybody in
it's just that's like a much more kind
of like classical system but it's you're
not able to kind of like scale
immediately to 65 countries in the world
that way yeah you know what you're doing
is you built a like a one-month online
and you're gonna have different leaders
with office hours in these
transformative spaces I really like that
it's all you know not again you're just
not a not a normal model where it's
equity based or we give you your first
round of funding base that's not like
that it's way more based on like who are
you over there in this other part of the
world what is this transformative idea
that you have for unleashing human
potential and how can we be of help here
in the valley where we have a massive
concentration of smart people that can
that can unlock your maybe some of your
ignorance around what is going on with
HRV because we already have done it in
so much more detail maybe we can ship
you out some EEG headsets for you to go
and start actually doing more detailed
scientific work on what you know we just
connecting you to the right to the right
people because you know the weave you
and I have talked about this a little
bit but you know I I have both I have a
tremendous amount of excitement and
optimism and I'll tell you why in a
second and I also have a tremendous
sense of urgency yeah the optimism comes
from you know one can sort of like hope
and dream for something as much as you
want to but you really need a confluence
of you know need demanded means for
something to take off and that's what
happened in the last you know call it a
year year and a half on the need side a
lot of it was driven by
health care cost people really
understanding the impact that stress and
anxiety is having on corporate health
care cost cities municipalities also
with the rise in healthcare cost and
just the changes you know in the
healthcare system for example in the US
with a lot of costs going back to people
they're starting to think a lot more
preventive you know because it's like
they might actually not have health care
coverage and so people are just like
it's becoming more accepted and then
also the other big thing is lots of you
know lots of people that people would
not expect coming forth and saying I'm
having a hard time whether it's an
entertainer or a entrepreneur or you
know the people that you know have
passed this year from suicide and so
there's just like this understanding of
you know the human mind people are
having a hard time and then the second
part in all the cost associated with it
so like stress alone in the u.s. is
estimated to be a 350 billion dollar
annual cost for corporations that's huge
yeah that's just you stress that's just
that's nothing else that's not
loneliness which is you know worse for
you than obesity
that's just stress on that that one
thing then the second pillar is demand
and demand has everything to do with you
know behavior cultural acceptance and
you see some really wonderful things
like Millennials in the u.s. already
today spend the fourth of their
disposable income on well-being you know
and so they are so they're already
saying we want this other things like in
future work studies on them is that they
believe that the world should change or
they believe that a lot of the change in
the world should happen through business
so they have very high expectations for
what's supposed to happen in the
companies that they work at and they're
not quite bought into sort of like the
way the world they were looking at their
parents they're like you're
happy you know and so they're not bought
into that I've worked with a lot of
Millennials and when I ran World of
Warcraft in China when I operated it my
whole style and it was six years is the
director of ops and Blizzard by the way
for China for China just China just
China but still like whoa and it's like
you know I like I find the millennial
and younger generation to be I am so
inspired by them you know what what
doesn't work for them is command and
control like you can't say do it because
I told you to which is I'm totally fine
with that you know but if you attach it
to their Y then they're the
hardest-working people I have ever seen
yes and so that's showing up and like
the way that they're thinking about
things so they're interested in
well-being
they already prefer experiences to
things so that's already showing up and
how they're spending their money
totally and so there's this you know and
they wanna see have you heard that one
yet what's that if they do it for the
Instagram experiences all the things
yeah totally totally and then also I
think you know I mean I think when I
look at certain people who are you know
controversial about certain things you
know that are people who are talking
about very structures like cleaning your
room and stuff like that what I think is
not going to that but what it says to me
is like it's like the world is searching
for a new narrative mm-hmm
people are searching for a new narrative
that's how to put it like what is it
we're supposed to be doing and that
really ties your pretty tapped into that
I like that yeah well and so that ties
to the urgency but also ties to the
future of work and purpose and meaning
and transformative technology because
you know and I've kind of gone off a
little bit and I'll circle back to the
the third reason why I'm excited which
is the means part and maybe I'll just
say that and then come back so I don't
go too far you've been a great stream of
caution
so it's need demand so we're seeing the
demand the rising generation wants to be
happy they want meaning they want
fulfillment and is showing up and its
global it's not just the US when you
look at sentiment and stuff like that
global sentiment and then the third part
is the means and so a lot of this is
driven by exponential technology and you
know the ability for emotion recognition
behavior recognition pattern recognition
and we absolutely have to figure out
data ownership privacy ethics like all
of that stuff like cannot be left to
chance
yeah but urgency yeah but it's like the
assessment power like if you we kind of
talked about this before if you knew as
much about yourself as Google and
Facebook did there isn't anything you
couldn't do like nothing right yeah
exactly key why don't we just I've
always wanted to just have that mirrored
at me at least show me who I am the only
way I can see Who I am on these
platforms if I go back and look through
my photos over the last like four years
yeah yeah and it doesn't what it doesn't
do is it doesn't you know it's all about
UI UX it is all about and it's a it's a
load of poop right now right and it's
it's it's fine it's it's like you're
scratching the service of surface of the
potential of psychometric profiling
being mirrored back towards me and
you're serving you as opposed that
they're just trying to feed us this
massive Thanksgiving turkey dinner
instead of serving my heart and my mind
at all like it's totally different yeah
time well-spent
because it's like right now you know I
love Tristan Harris
and I also like I have I have a mat like
I just I also love Joe Edelman who is a
UX UI designer and he's just like blows
my mind he was the person who gave me
hope about you know how we sort of like
get get out of the metrics mess you know
that companies are built on and how
things are designed this is a radical
shift in the user interface and
experience like you were saying and I
think that I've been dreaming up a
interface for the last couple months
myself and a big problem with me
executing that project is it is
basically a Apple sized project it's
it's it's a you need some of the best
designers and engineers out there in
order to really make this technology of
radically available to as many people as
possible especially without just one of
the departments at Google or Apple or
Facebook just being like oh do you see
that let's all dedicate a crapload of
resources to that which is also fine
because at least it starts the domino
effect across but at the same time you
want to kind of keep as ask someone that
views themselves as more ethically or
morally grounded in many ways
philosophically grounded globally ground
and consciously grounded like can we
just steer the bull with our own power
and not just be like oh it's fine you
take over so yeah so so in the sense I
want to build this out and I have this
massive vision for it and there's so
many different ways to be able to string
it together visually that's pleasing you
when you when you log when you log into
Facebook you're sent to your newsfeed
what if you were rather sent to a just a
quick refresher on on like Allen do you
remember moving back to the Bay Area six
years ago and that shows you a couple
photos of you moving to the Bay and then
it's like you know we noticed that you
have a
you know you haven't connected to these
people that have that you have a hundred
and twenty mutual friends with and it
shows you these three people's faces and
it's like would you like to reach out to
any of them right now yeah they're doing
a little bit with memories and some
others yeah but if they're so sprinkled
in there that and then also on like
there's so many other options with Gmail
and write the way they lose a really
cool product that the founder is going
to and CEO is going to be speaking at
that transformative tech conference it's
called trip and basically what it is is
it's you said you you pick your state
that you want to experience and it's you
know it's a game it's a VR experience
but as you're going through it the
photos and the music and the things that
are integrated are things that you
associate with happiness or that you
associate it with you know also it's
like people one of the things that I
love about what they're doing is they're
gonna allow people to also do sadness
you know it's because there's like
there's something about nostalgia about
that you know that that relationship
that period of time and you know that's
okay because a lot of this you know this
is not about programming over and over
again can cause a lot of suffering well
it's it's not about programming humans
to not have emotions it's not about that
it's about helping people have the skill
in order to you know in order to process
and understand what's happening navigate
and to navigate it you know it's like
you know anyone who is an adult he's
going to you were going to have you know
heartbreak disappointment betrayal you
know like your best friend needs you
know it's gonna when you're six it's got
to pick a new best friend
you know like these things happen but
it's how you deal with it in the meaning
that you make and the
self-awareness that you have and so you
know to get back to the means on the
three parts of you know need demand and
means what's happening now especially
with the with the exponential
technologies and so you know like all
the things you know AI 3d printing
networks and sensors and like everything
else that's exponential is now allowing
us to have a kind of a portability
sensing you know it's like there's
things like I've seen things like you
know you can for example you can pick up
heart rate not her great variability
it's not good enough yet but you could
pick up heart rate through the eye
that's like a camera in the eye because
you can't see it and I can't see it but
it's like your you know our faces change
colors with our heartbeat it's very
minimal yeah but a computer can pick it
up let us the pump to the extremity of
the skin yeah and so now heart rate
variability there's too much artifact in
it right now it's like because a heart
rate and heart rate variability no it's
not the same but that's a math problem
and we know what happens to math
problems in the era of exponential tech
right it's only a matter of time and so
you know one of my favorite quotes is Jo
Ito it's got this great quote where he
says that you know a hundred years from
now technology should be
indistinguishable from nature and I love
that because it suggests as a design
imperative that we move it to the
background you know a lot of people are
so you know when they hear well being in
tech they're like oh those two things
are opposed in that is that is only the
current situation because we haven't
designed it better and we're in charge
of that it's like tech is not
deterministic we design it so we could
design it with the intention that it
goes to the background so this stuff
goes to the foreground you know and that
is like that's a design principle or
people are like you know well what if I
lose the you know if you're always
telling me what my heart rate
variability is what if I lose the
ability because one of the most
powers you get in meditation is like a
real sense of state and what if I lose
the ability to do that it's like well
when you've got that first bike when you
got that banana bike when you were a kid
with the training wheels you never
expect it to be have the training wheels
on 20 years later they're not designed
to stay on we just designed them did
let's design it to take it off and then
after you have that level of skill then
there's something else if you're worried
about like what is the product roadmap
this is all design right and so you know
people are getting like you know
justifiably you know bent out of shape
over you know the phone but getting bent
out of shape over this without thinking
about what we could do is like getting
bent out of shape over the stone wheel
it's like it's like you know or getting
or today getting bent out of shape about
vanilla ice it's like it's over you know
it's like you should be looking ahead we
need to be looking ahead and designing
what we need and how do we establish you
know my framework is you know assessment
the assessment power that this
technology can oh yeah the assessment
power that this technology can provide
for us amplification as a great you know
possibility for how we interact with AI
and how we use AI to amplify human you
know human skills and the human soft
skills so sent our therapists sent our
mentors how we do knowledge transfer yep
you know and then enhancing our natural
you know understanding so like one of my
favorite examples is a heart rate
variability training at the Santa Clara
Police Department and so they used
physical sensors to help them train to
be able to feel their heart rate
variability so they knew when they were
you know going into yeah when they were
getting overstressed and the quote that
I think was the most telling was one of
the police officers said you know I've
done a lot of psychological training but
the physical component of this made it
so real to me that I use it
you know and so people say when people
look at a study that says dogs are
apathetic and they're like Oh someone
did the science on that well there is
something about measurement that makes
it real for humans yeah and we're so
good with feedback we're like feedback
processing machines and so when we get
feedback those better than others yeah
yeah well or our signals feedback that
we're willing to accept let's say it
that way but learning how to talk is a
feedback system learning how to walk
like gravity is a great feedback system
so we're feedback processing machines
and so you know the ability to get
feedback on our internal state in a
ui/ux that's not distracting that's
supportive that helps us understand
what's going on you know like that would
unlock notice so you've been sitting for
15 minutes you should stand up and
stretch you know there's so many young
ones that just come to mind and yeah
yeah and then that last part about
connecting because you know if you think
about the problems that are facing
mankind and you know there's a lot that
we know that we just don't have the will
to do but there's a lot that we don't
know and a lot to be discovered and you
know when you look at the future of work
and this is going to the urgency and
then I'll sheesh but you know when you
look at the future of work and the
importance of creativity and
collaboration and then you think of all
those things one of the things that
they're built on is they're built on
trust and if you you know and in the old
school way of things doing things when
companies were silos you know you had
plenty of time to get to know one person
or your team or whatever but the way the
things because from a you know the
consumer space you know the you know
Sarah in Kansas City doesn't care if the
person who runs marketing is different
than the person who runs the customer
service she doesn't care you know it's
all one thing to her and so she has a
bad experience it doesn't matter who was
in charge of that so what's happening on
the company side is that people are
realizing they can't run organizations
and silos anymore it has to be
integrated team so you're seeing lots of
teams of teams and people are having to
come together and move a part of coming
move apart and also just you know most
startups many startups die because of
the team not necessarily because of they
had the wrong bet and so this ability to
like establish trust a lot of its based
on self trust and self trust comes from
a combination of who you think you are
and having gone through processes of
understanding that but also like
self-knowledge comes from you know what
your body says and that we can get at
that with Transtech transform and attack
and then also what your behavior says
and that's where like you know what did
you really do because a lot of times who
we think we are or what we think we're
doing and what we're actually doing are
not the same thing and if we had
visibility and that we'd be like oh I'm
not actually doing that because there's
a bunch of you know there's a bunch of
stuff that shows that human memory is
totally faulty yeah and when we try and
quantify our own actions we typically
think that we're doing something that is
that we're falling through on when we're
actually not in many ways so yeah it's
good to get objective feedback about
what the mirror on myself you you just
listed so many important things I don't
I can't even recall oh you a question
like like 30 45 oh thank you Eddie man
and we're just kind of oh man Nicole we
haven't even really like we're just
surface well this is what happens when
you are explaining all these different
things of such complexity for for the I
guess for the first time to me at this
at this level and I find it to be just
super inspirational I'm really excited
for the Academy and all the students
that are gonna be coming in from around
the world that are gonna be getting
mentorship and and hopefully executing
their ideas yeah it's just definitely
scratching the surface I really
appreciate you teaching us about things
like you know trip as well these sort of
yeah that's Nanao reeves and she is
ass what's her name Nanea Reeves Nanao
Reeves yeah and just you know that that
reminds me a lot of these kind of like
that's just the simulation that's you
know why we call the show this is
because it's not just related to a
simulation theory and it's not just
related to you know if we're alone in
the cause and loss and it's not just
related to a complete VR simulation
where it's indistinguishable and stuff
but even something like simulating a
state of happiness or a state of
frustration or whatever the state is and
just showing you what that's like and
just reminding you what that's like it's
just it's just a good way to have a
mirror and we don't have enough mirrors
we don't have enough of these sort of
like objective measurements for
well-being joy prosperity etcetera and I
think that you know you're really at
that key you're you're kind of like the
key I don't think yeah I don't think I
know other people in Silicon Valley that
are as much of a key to this as you are
so thank you the blessing to feature a
lot of people but you know nobody really
speaks about it as you know
multidisciplinary as you do and I love
that there's so much more to unpack is
there another key thing that we should
unpack on our way yeah well and I want
to say why this sense of urgency yeah
and and how much time I think we have I
I think that we have roughly 10 to 15
years Oh what would happen if we didn't
have a sense of urgency well - so - to
uplevel the social and emotional skill
level of the human race I agree with you
that's good like that's about that's the
time that we have so I have a sense of
urgency before there could be a massive
sort of wine well you know I believe
that's when you're gonna see them that's
rough estimates that's when you're gonna
start to see major major job transition
and that's when the 47% of these jobs
are starting to massively shift to ship
ship ship ship ship
yeah and so but I also you know it's
like 10 years in tech is like a thousand
years today you know like it's moving so
fast
yes it's ten years in from from like
2020 to 2030 will be like as much
technological advance as like 1900 to
2000 yeah and there's there's so much
there's like other stuff that you know
it's happening like you know the ability
to do deep brain stimulation you know
there's like there's so many advances
that are happening and so I'm incredibly
optimistic and and it really is because
of this nice life kind of flirty demand
and means we finally have that we
finally have that so we can actually do
something we can do something about it
and and we should because I think you
know I don't there isn't and I say this
often in my talks because I feel so
strongly about it but you know there is
no nobler purpose for technology than to
bring peace to the mind of mankind and I
and I want that for us because one I
feel a responsibility to do a proper
handover but I don't mean you know I
feel like I want to do a proper proper
handover to the children of the world
and to it's like you know the bless you
for thinking that way I don't think I
know people think that way oh yeah
that's a boy well and and then just
curiosity like my my best and my worst
trait it you know is my curiosity
there's a whole cosmos out there for us
yeah you know and so I think that we can
solve the problems that we have I think
that the state of the human mind is the
key to it you know I think if we can
bring the fear level down put some of
the fires out raise the skill level up
yeah you know and then you know unlocks
and you know unlocks and bigger levels
yeah I think I think it's absolutely
totally doable
I like the transformative tech level
that's being unlocked yeah and I like
your sense of urgency
I like your macro view on things like
how you look from the moon
earth and you kind of see what's going
on across all the disciplines because
you see the issue with mental health and
you see the issue with automation and
then you see the issue of this lacking
socio-emotional awareness and thriving
and that we all have a sense of urgency
around it and you know and and bless the
pursuits at which you're tackling this
through yeah the transformative tech
pursuits a really good one to address
this might even be you know the best one
and so in order for us to to help push
marbles in that direction I think a
really good way of doing so is to you
know check out the links in the bio but
also just get involved in general with
attending the conference getting
involved in the Academy
maybe supporting the lab in ways yeah
and I think one thing I want to end with
you know it's like sometimes when people
hear me talk about this they're like
they still if it's new to them they
think it's a theory it's not a theory
we've done a list for the last couple of
years called the transformative tech 200
and those are only 200 companies that we
think are really cool you know and so
there are like there are real products
there are so many real products in this
category like our mutual friend Harpreet
yes we Ryan ordering yeah ring your
heart rate variability and your heart
rate and your sleep cycles all they're
just wearing a very through a very thin
small ring throughout the day and at
night and it's just it's really you know
having people like that kind of take the
stage and speak about you know human
health insurance transformation into
understanding oneself yeah we put sleep
in because if you can't sleep you can't
have well-being like it's not available
to you if you can't sleep and so sleep
is a category that we we track
Nicole I just can't you know it's so
difficult to actually to figure out like
like how do haha you know we'd like we
would just scratch the surface is so
difficult to be able to dive deeper
transform technology didn't even talk
about human consciousness we didn't talk
about human consciousness we didn't talk
about group flow and how that could sort
of like completely unlock teams in
humanity we didn't talk about struggle
versus suffering struggle is good
suffering you know I think we can do
something about that we I guess we'll
have to do another yeah I have to have
partnership yeah part two will have to
happen before the conference yeah let's
make it happen before the conference
just another thing that really came to
mind throughout is that this you you
really made it clear that there needs to
be some sort of an augmentation in the
in the interface and the experience that
we have with technology and you know
this sort of vision that's in that's in
mind about it it's just the way that we
engage with with technology just being
so much more you know three-dimensional
rather than you know two-dimensional
static screen is a three dimensional and
using your hands and using your voice
and being able to pull things apart and
send them off physically you know and
send that that way and you know increase
the size of something paint it blue with
the beautiful wheel that pops up and it
changed the size you know it's just the
way that we engage with this stuff is
just so it feels primordial compared to
what is the next iteration yes and I
want to build the next iterations and I
don't want someone else to build it
because I think that other people are
going to stumble ethically as they build
it
and I think there are people like you
that won't but I think there's
interestingly enough there's like you
were saying there's so many people at
companies right now like Salesforce and
like LinkedIn and all these other places
that would thrive as entrepreneurs so
another thought in my head was like you
know the teal fellowship of like getting
the kids out of that when they're 18 19
and just taking them into
entrepreneurship I was thinking like it
would be equally as fun to be like yo
people that work at all these technology
companies you probably have five ten
fifteen thousand dollars in your savings
accounts because you get paid five K a
month or more so so really you have the
best potential pretty much to be able to
drop what you're doing at this major
company and go and start something in
transformative technology or in biotech
or in whatever field and and you and
there's this massive support network of
people that would love to help you
succeed in that pursuit they themselves
have like a one-year runway in their
savings at least from what they've saved
up at these companies and they can all
follow along in the program as well so
you know we're accepting people who
don't currently have companies because
you know I think a lot of great people
are working other places right now who
will you like someone is going to build
something extraordinary in this space
and today they are working somewhere
else
yep and then the people that come into
the Academy that are not selected by you
is there still a way for them to go
through the process or they yeah they
can well I mean we are we are selecting
yeah but we have two tracks that the
people that we select we you know go to
and people say which track they want to
be on but if someone is selected for the
innovator track then they they're able
to follow along we're gonna have a group
slack and they'll be connected to the
community they'll be able to you know
talk with people around the world we
have country managers we have over 40
country managers and
several of the country managers are
organizing live events in their cities
to do like founder dating so people who
are not on teams but want to can meet
each other and maybe magic happens
maybe magic happens you know I basically
marriage yeah it's totally yes we are
not we're not you know doing matching
but we're creating the space for
matching good so that you know people
can find one another I'm just thinking
is there another big one on here that we
should show a big slide that's really
important I mean I mean you list so many
important things so how the [ __ ] do we
cover all of this so this is a drastic
Andy for episode two yeah yeah Nicole I
I my mind is just this blow and my heart
feels like just it's it's more it's
closer to you know it's closer to I
think it's closer to the spirit I think
it's closer to keep man anything's
closer to you I think it's closer to
your mission and values and it's it's
not every single show where I feel that
way and so it's yeah it's it's nice yeah
so much love okay I want to ask you just
these couple classic questions that we
asked along the way out do you think
we're alone in the cosmos no and unpack
that a little for us well there's just
so many like I just the cosmos is so big
I can't imagine that we are the only
life in the entire cosmos that doesn't
mean you know right I can't imagine
where the only life I am also like we've
got plenty to take care of here so I
don't you know I don't need to have
proof tomorrow one way or the other but
I believe it is likely that there is
life on other planets
and then do you think we're in a
simulation no I don't I don't well I
don't think we're in a simulation though
I do think we're in a game unpack that
oh well I mean you know it so you know I
spent a lot of my life on the back end
of World of Warcraft and so you know in
a role-playing game you you go on
experiences and you take your avatar on
experiences and through these
experiences you level you know I think
that a friend of mine when he asked
someone how old them they are he doesn't
say how old are you he says what level
are you which sounds so much color so if
you're if you're level 57 if you're
level 68 you know my my auntie is you
know level 70 something you know like
that's you know that's so much sounds so
much cooler you arrest taught us about
how he thought that a lot of people were
at a very low level societies very much
like a bunch of toddlers and children
and there's only a couple teenagers
around and there's nobody that's an
adult in society
and it's very and we need people that
are adults and grandparents to help
guide civilization and so with a bunch
of toddlers running around and then now
we have AI warfare and all the [ __ ] it's
gonna be really tough anyway continue I
like what you're saying you're an app
you're you're in a role-playing game
tell us more and it's also so I mean I
have a I have a pretty intense
meditative practice one of the reasons
why I start my presentations many of
them out with homo Deus is because with
sapiens you've all her re blew my mind
yes and you know when I when I read that
book basically the the net one of the
net takeaways was that you know culture
is not solid yeah you know and at the
same time I was you know I hang out with
a lot of neuroscientist
and just how much the brain fills in of
our experience you know we're kind of
you know so if cultures not solid we're
kind of creating culture on the fly our
brain is creating reality on the fly
yeah and then deep Buddhist philosophy
with the sense doors and a bunch of
other stuff which we don't have to go
into reality is also being created on
the fly and nothing is solid and
everything is impermanent and so when
that like when all of that came into my
brain at the same time instead of
feeling a sense of you know bad vertigo
I was like oh my god we can change it we
could do we can design it we can change
it we can do like we don't have to
accept what this is yeah and so that was
really kind of that was super inspiring
so I don't think we're in a simulation
and if we are if we aren't you know
unless we're gonna like pull them crawl
everything change that well will
essentially she's just like we're in
some sort of holodeck and there's like
mountains of running it can be tons of
different definitions well I think the
reality is way more than what we see an
experience yes and that we haven't
unlocked that but I think that we will
at some point in human experience I know
that you you know from meditative
practices and you know and I follow I
follow Dan Brown and some other amazing
teachers but just you know the things
that I've been able to experience in my
own reality yeah I definitely don't
think that you know reality is as we
commonly accept it and I think that you
know as we understand more and more I
think I think science and our
understanding of you know matter in the
nature of reality will only continue to
expand so I don't think it's a
simulation but I do think that it's a
game and I think that it can be
more I think it can be easier to
navigate and I think that's one of the
things that Judas formative technology
you could provide yeah
there's a lot of what I'm writing about
right now was making it easier to
navigate yeah no that's what they very
aligned in that sense last question what
do you think those beautiful thing in
the world you you that is actually you
know it's like I'm in the place in my
practice where you what I find to be
true is that getting a little choked up
about this what I find to be true is
that if you actually look at someone
yeah and you really see them yeah
there's no matter who they are it
doesn't have to be silence usually it
takes silence and just looking at
someone's eyes and just you'd be
vulnerable well if you really see a
person they don't even have to look at
you you can be people watching walks but
if you look and you really see someone
they become like you see that they are
extraordinarily beautiful yeah you know
like humans are so beautiful
that's that activity you just walk
around at an event where everybody's
just you you walked and then you stop
find a person closest to you and you
just look at them in the eyes and you
don't speak and you just keep looking at
them in the eyes and then you just be
that can be kind of creepy unless they
knows and that's what's going on
everybody in the rooms doing okay oh oh
you didn't mean like any event it's like
baby died yeah yeah but it when
everyone's on that same page yeah you're
doing that that's exactly what you're
describing is exactly that I'm glad that
you bring that up because I and I think
it restores some of the humanity in us
and I think a lot of a lot of
that occurs is when we lose a sense of
that humanity and other people yeah the
bottom line is this like you know
everybody no matter where they are in
the world no matter what their culture
is everyone wants to be loved
oh this is the Maslow slide yeah
everyone wants to be loved to connect to
belong and to you know to feel that they
are having progress in their life yes
towards something whatever it is yes
like those are the things that people
love connect along and have progress
toward something in their lives
yeah that's that's it and we all share
it yeah and I find the most beautiful
you know what I find to be the most
beautiful is like humans so yeah
beautiful yeah yeah I wonder if like
caterpillars think that way that people
have love connected the login that I do
not know I wonder what is that brain
sort of silent size to mass of having
that one having that one like you do
humans would do dolphins have it do so I
don't know but like one of the things
that's interesting you see on this this
hierarchy most people believe that or
most people think that the hierarchy
Maslow's hierarchy ended with so far
self-actualization but there is self
transcendence yeah and he actually like
he just he just wished the rest thanked
in there they'll listen won't you won't
you say well self here's the difference
so self-actualization is like what
everybody in the bay does right like
making the things happen that you want
to happen totally self transcendence is
when you realize that that self that you
actualized you don't need anymore and so
to your question about are we in the
simulation or in the game there is a
point where you know the there's a point
with self transcendence when you don't
need that self that you actualized yeah
and you realize that you know that you
don't need that you actually transcend
the game yeah and then it's a whole yeah
then
then there's a whole nother level
there's a whole nother level I love that
you walk up to people you're like what
level you at yeah yeah yeah Nicole I
can't I can't stop thinking about the
show this has been fantastic thank you
for having me because it's such a
freaking pleasure I knew we were gonna
have fun yeah it's all of our
conversations are fun but I blew my mind
this time when they blew my mind this is
so cool and okay I'm so grateful thank
you and thank you everybody for tuning
in if you guys had a good time
definitely comment with your thoughts
below go and check out the links in the
bio to transformative technology to the
conference to the Academy into the lab
go check it out please join in the
conversation subscribe also build
something with this content don't just
consume it go make other video content
go write about it go start companies
with it you know what to do go create
during some patreon help us support this
grow it impact it help us you know
launch off more of the transformative
technologies that are going on we would
love your assistance with that thank you
so much to Eddie
our producer and director much love to
Eddie thank you and thanks everybody and
we'll see you soon thank you
[Music]
[Music]